[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different than
usual
rather than deep diving into the rich
lore of harry potter
i'm going to instead be taking a look at
the casting decisions made
for the harry potter films now i thought
the casting in harry potter was great
across pretty much all of the films for
pretty much all of the roles
there wasn't a single role where i felt
that the actor themself
took away from the character however
there were of course some instances in
which the film portrayal of the
character
didn't exactly fit with the book i.e
bonnie wright with
ginny and while i think that the harry
potter films did a fantastic job overall
i can't quite say the same for the
fantastic beasts films
at least the ones we've had so far they
weren't bad
but definitely not as good as harry
potter even the characters that we hate
like umbridge were cast exceptionally
well imelda stoneton was the
perfect umbrage but like with any film
casting is a huge part of the film
creation process
and so it only makes sense that many
many other actors were nearly cast in
these roles
in this video we're going to be taking a
closer look at some of the actors
that were ever so close to being cast in
some of these roles
some didn't get the role because they
were beat out by someone who was just a
better fit
and others weren't able to accept the
role due to things like scheduling
conflicts
without further ado let's take a look at
some of the actors
that could have been number one hugh
grant
the first actor that we're going to be
looking at is british rom-com heartthrob
hugh grant
grant is predominantly known for his
comedic performances in romantic
comedies
but in more recent years seems to have
branched out a little bit
perhaps in fear of being labeled a
one-trick pony grant was originally cast
as
you guessed it wizarding heartthrob
gilderoy lockhart
five-time winner of which weekly's most
charming smile award
the role of lockhart required an actor
that was able to effectively convey the
painfully cheesy and simultaneously
egotistical nature
of the character and grant us cheese
well
lockhart was of course harry's defense
against the dark arts professor
in the chamber of secrets and his
character exudes an unusual mixture of
charming
and despicable the role of course
eventually went to kenneth branagh
but this was actually only because grant
turned the role down
grant was in the middle of filming some
other things and it just didn't work out
with his schedule
fortunately however brana did an
excellent job though i'm sure grant
would have done well in the role as well
number two ian mckellen gandalf is that
you
yes that's right so ian mckellen
famously known as the powerful wizard
gandalf in the lord of the rings
and magneto and x-men was actually
considered as a front-runner
for dumbledore as we know richard harris
the original dumbledore
who was only in the first two films
passed away before the film series could
be completed
this meant that one of the largest roles
in the film franchise
suddenly became vacant and it only seems
fitting that warner brothers would want
to cast someone very experienced
ian mckellen is an incredibly versatile
actor and given that he is already an
accomplished on-screen wizard
it made sense that he would be
considered for dumbledore interestingly
enough
richard harris who originally played
dumbledore did not think particularly
highly of mckellen's acting capabilities
and once publicly expressed that he
thought that mckellen was
brilliant but passionless i'm not sure
if this had any bearing in casting but
the role was eventually given to michael
gambon
who absolutely crushed it gambon is an
irish-born british actor
who trained under lawrence olivier
himself and has an extremely impressive
acting resume under his belt
he performed exceptionally well in the
role and i honestly think that he did a
better job than mckellen would have done
even her mckellen is a great actor
number 3 tim roth
actor tim roth is known for his roles in
popular films like
pulp fiction reservoir dogs the hit and
many many more he's an english actor
with quite a diverse acting background
and with his years of experience i feel
as though he's the kind of actor that
could take on any sort of role
however the role that roth was
originally supposed to take on
was none other than potions professor
severus snape
the role of severus snape was of course
later filled by actor alan rickman
who portrayed snape in a way that i
don't think any other actor could
of all of the casting in harry potter i
think that snape may have been the best
when i saw his character on screen
i didn't think oh that's alan rickman i
just thought
that snape which if you consider the
fact that rickman was already quite
famous
is quite an impressive feat he
completely submerged himself into the
role
and they can't even begin to imagine
anyone else being snape
though i'm sure roth could have given it
a go it couldn't have worked out better
that he had to turn the role down
roth was first in line but dropped out
so that he could film tim burton's
planet of the apes
number 4. tilde swinton matilda or tilda
swinton
is a scottish actress known for her
roles in both independent art house
films and blockbusters
over the course of her career she's been
cast in a very diverse array of roles
and i personally felt that she was
particularly good in the role of the
white witch
in the chronicles of narnia in whatever
film i see her in
she always has a lot of screen presence
and with her scottish background
i'm sure she would have slotted in
perfectly with the harry potter set
swinton was originally considered for
the role of professor trelawny
the quirky unusual and perhaps sometimes
deluded divination professor
the role of trelloni was of course
eventually given to actress emma
thompson
who did an exceptional job but i
honestly feel as though swinton
would have done a pretty good job here
as well swinton was offered the role
before thompson
but had to turn it down due to
scheduling conflicts
number 5 robin williams the late robin
williams was an exceptional actor
he had an extremely impressive acting
resume and over the course of his career
was always able to effectively portray
whatever was asked of him
his ability to convey emotion on screen
was a true testament to his acting
capabilities
and charisma in addition to being a
popular stand-up comic
williams also had impressive
improvisational skills and is perhaps
best known for his roles in films like
dead poets society good will hunting and
mrs doubtfire
williams was initially considered for
the role of hogwarts gamekeeper
rubius hagrid and was actually the first
choice of warner brothers
however the role was eventually extended
to actor robbie coltrane
as rowling wanted to preserve an
all-british cast coltrane did an
exceptional job at portraying the gentle
magical half giant
and once again i feel as though he was
the perfect casting decision
however i can't help but wonder what
williams would have been like in the
role
number 6. bob hoskins the late bob
hoskins was an english actor best known
for portraying
tough guys gangsters and working-class
gentlemen
one of his most well-known roles was
eddie valiant in who framed roger rabbit
an iconic live-action animated comedy
released in 1988.
hoskins was initially considered for the
role of potions professor
horace slughorn the eccentric teacher
that had a knack
for collecting his students hoskins lost
out on the role to english actor jim
broadbent
who i know i keep saying this was
perfect in the role
though i feel that hoskins would have
given us quite a different
representation of slughorn
i think he would have still done well in
the role in spite of hoskins being
turned down
for the role of slughorn it has been
reported that rowling wanted hoskins in
the film so
badly that she even considered writing a
role for him in the seventh book
number 7. jk rowling jk rowling
have you heard the name before though
rowling is certainly not an actress
she was originally considered for the
role of harry's mother in the
philosopher's stone which could have
perhaps been a nice cameo
i think that of all of the roles lily
possa would have been the perfect role
for her to slot herself into
had she wanted to enter the film however
rowling and the casting directors
eventually decided that it would be best
that they go with someone else
though it's not a particularly large
role actress
geraldine summerville who eventually
went on to assume the role
did a good job and that's it for this
video did you guys know about all of
these potential casting decisions
do you think that any of these actors
would have been better in the role
than the actors that were cast let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
you